Friday ladies gentlemen I'm wearing a
cashmere sweater now it's summertime
it's summertime a dominant thing is I I
cranked the air conditioning up in my
house so I got a little chill it's like
my grandmother was like I have a chill
my grandmother my mother this is this is
this is always cold this is this is an
impression of them they were this way
when they were 30 they and no matter
where you're sitting no matter where I'm
my grandmother my mother goes is there a
draft I feel like there's a trap first
of all sorry you guys about my awesome
sunglasses wouldn't know wouldn't you I
feel like you can take Monday I get the
stitches out but I feel let's take a
little gander see I would I would well I
wouldn't Rock the sunglasses I'm a
little swollen
day three a little small hunting
sunglasses in here no no I think you're
good I don't like sunglass now you look
like you're going into the eighth round
I do I take a swimming but I'm still
coming you're still coming still coming
you're very Mickey war yes and there are
plenty of fighters that looked like this
who came still came okay before it
there's there's yeah I was when I was
backstage I grow even Donna we fought
Robbie Lawler yep well that was he
couldn't see he said I wasn't able to
say daddy can you see I can see a little
bit get a little dizzy
it itches pink it's just [ __ ] where's
the stitches that right there look they
still use like the the thread stitch and
they don't you the one you do they do
all this all fallible you know look at
Robbie Lawler I mean I mean roaring down
oh my god well that sir that changed
everything
yes but sir you're very similar than
that especially on Wednesday Jesus I
always wanted to look like Rory
MacDonald and well there goes i I just
think they should stop fights
Robbie Lars but did but I can't believe
they're still using the thread stitching
why don't these the dissolve so you have
to go back in well I don't know because
I'm not a plastic surgeon you know what
they probably know better than they
probably know a little better that it's
like they're dying is like sobs I'll
shut your me like dr. diamond said he
goes I go you've done this before he
goes a couple times a couple of times
it's so routine for those guys we met
with our business guy knee goes oh I saw
your picture of Brian and you know we're
I'll surprise him but you got the
surgery he goes the only people I know I
got the surgery in high school the cream
girl's got it done because they didn't
yes that's a very pious to be more round
it's very precise in Korea Korea in high
school though yeah it's the most popular
so almost all the kpop you would know
yeah the kpop fun women and men get
their eyes I guess as you guys
everything yeah little details well did
they have custom implants for your jaw's
for your for your cheekbones
they have custom plenty implants for
everything they have filler they have
everything you can imagine they well I
mean see the car - like no one talks
about it like no one's like oh I got
this done like you'll just see a girl
like oh I promise like she black and
blue problem is it ruins things for you
there was a girl in Malibu I'm sitting
there and with with my friends and and
there's a girl in Malibu and I'm sitting
there and and she had a high I looked at
her cheekbones and I went to high state
she just looked she was pretty she had
cheekbones and the woman next to me said
that's filler and I went no she goes
that and they all knew everybody at the
table who was from LA I went I'm naive
too of course you I have no because it's
so subtle and so good but there there
was a shiny there was a shiny Hill
perfectly right here where it did
wouldn't make sense but it looks great
so for me looks good I'm not if that's
what you want to do I mean we don't know
how it's gonna look when she's 40 well
do you know what it's a very popular
surgery that people don't know about men
or women women one of the most popular
is they'll just young girls they'll just
lift your brows they'll just go they'll
just take your face and they will go OOP
and what that does no yeah you don't
need it at all
Kat what they do is wrinkle if you're if
you're not lucky like Kat
some women have apparently this is this
would be the thing that they'll talk
about they have their eyebrows kind of
fall well yeah you know your forehead
looks like the belly of an earthworm
that's exactly right that's exactly
right what they'll do though we'll get
into that in a second in a second
I've been around they'll just lift it
bang they'll just bang they lift it up
and now you got and now you've got a
little bit more arch to your eyebrows
now what they have to do when they do
that however your if they got it off
they got it
separate where do they scan from here
all the way down to here again not in
the operating room but this is what I
understand worth it and then you bug
your heel and your back your butt you
can do so much to your face in your body
and be back to normal and you're out for
two months yeah two months so I guess
these instances take a week sometimes
like a bunch of pictures yeah oh she
looks surprised there you go
yeah but it don't look like but it but
it but it does raise your eyebrows make
sure yeah yeah that's a very popular
thing you Brian
now the face it was looks good
yeah he looks alert that that's a little
yeah with guys you got to be careful and
for whatever reason look like John
Travolta's like cheeks and fillers look
at how good that looks amazing yeah huge
difference and the your neck and stuff
the facelift is what a 13-hour operation
I mean the doctor standing over you and
sitting over you for 10 hours 11 hours
think about that an insurance to cover
any of this stuff right I don't think so
no look think it's gonna be I think if
you have it done with a really good guy
it's gonna you're looking at 2 to 5
hours for the face to 50 60 grand
I can't imagine just having my eyes done
which isn't painful how much cost a
grand and two in 17 so yeah ya know
especially in California you're looking
at yeah I would imagine you're getting
your face lifted you want to go to the
best it's gonna be sad to man yeah it's
you're fat a it so don't don't take
shortcuts it's a your tattoo don't seek
out the cheapest one well when people go
to just random countries although a
great place to go for you like heart
heart transplant or what our heart
surgery and stuff is India India in
Kedah Huebel you can get to Cuba has the
best I don't know if Cuba would do it
but I remember when uh my dad would we
grew up in the summers in Venice and
there was a billboard for when LASIK
first came out and said LASIK
two for one $79.99 and I was like dad
won't we why don't we could all bad I
said like why don't we do it he's like
you're an idiot
do you have bad eyesight I had I had
LASIK right ear oh yeah I don't know
yeah I still wear contacts and glasses
no yeah when did you get lazy
right that was my graduation gift from
my dad when I could graduate I've Spock
out of here from high school to college
on have done college now you can see
better so you can really get that
surgery look cuz when you get it done
you'll blind for about 20 seconds
fools everything goes dark and then it
comes right back very scary oh it's dude
it's good they do it with a laser and
it's painless right yeah you don't
really numb your eye I know they have to
make a little incision just on the and
peel back the opening flap and then the
laser goes into it's [ __ ] astonishing
that we can do that I think human beings
are complicated machines and we are just
we have the we're gonna become excellent
mechanics and the more we learn about
our own machine you can do anything you
can robot robots I would get an
artificial life if it was better and
maybe let's see like an eagle I don't
know what's like that you want I need
water I'm so sorry oh my god we go get
it myself like the Elon Musk thing where
they want to put that implant in your
head I don't want all that info dude I
don't wanna I don't then what's the
point of learning anything or reading
you're experiencing things like it just
land you can just just any information
like then there's really no reason to
argue either we both know the exact
facts to a tee there's no argument
there's no point of view which that was
just all well I had two thoughts today
so today is Juneteenth
this this celebrates I believe the day
that the slaves were emancipated
I think officially and and and so
there's a lot of push to make it a
national holiday and everything else but
certainly a very significant time in
American history and in fact if I do
again nothing but watch debates between
conservative and liberal black people
now and different ideas and what one of
the things is that the seven years after
reconstruction after the civil war was
in many ways the best time for
african-americans because they had a
great deal of political power they had
businesses and everything else and of
course the Jim Crow laws came along and
[ __ ] obliterated all that [ __ ] but um
but I've been thinking about two things
in this time of racial racial turmoil
and stuff like that technology is
getting us to a point in 50 years forty
years where
what it means to be human it's going to
be so different that it might in in 20
years it might flatten it might flatten
any difference at all because we are
going to mesh with machines and it's
gonna be a whole different thing so
that's good it not only is that scary
here's the other car heard I was thing
about this Jim Juneteenth stuff like and
they said the promise is you know
there's no social me there's no cell
phones there's no telephones so word
traveled really slow so can you imagine
if these slaves you you know some were
murdered you know right up till like
right sure like I just can't imagine
yeah and then getting the news like 12
days later like yeah I I had a really I
heard a really interesting point on this
to since today is the day of this
celebration and and it was [ __ ]
fascinating so most of the Democratic
Party
most of the liberal party most of the
left-wing is very against Trump's
immigration policy and against Trump's
wall and hardline immigration if you
look at the left Biden if you look at
all of the Democratic content and
candidates they kind of wanted to
decriminalize the border which means
that you're going to have a massive
influx of illegal immigration from
Guatemala Nicaragua Mexico and
everything else well you know what what
a lot of plaque pundits and thinkers are
saying and they're so right what they
were like there was this big debate with
Keller Mike and Candace Owens and Ti and
and uh people on both sides they are and
and I think it was can someone said we
are talking about how to have more power
right and we're talking about voting and
she said and if we don't do something
about illegal immigration none of this
matters none of our votes will matter
our votes will be inconsequential this
will all be for nothing
the irony is because the Latin vote and
especially the illegal it's gonna be so
many and they vote differently or they
blame these right no no Chinese is still
very very small but still three percent
of the popular is it
yeah even but that by the way only Asian
wealth per capita as far exceeded yeah
exceeded white well so you should be
talk about Asian Asian privilege guys
cuz you guys suffered no discrimination
at the hands of Americans oh my god but
it's really interesting because the left
is going to have to come to terms with
the fact that if you don't get serious
about [ __ ] immigration and illegal
immigration voting you are doing the
black people that you're talking about
the biggest is service because you're
gonna render their vote completely
irrelevant and if that happens
politicians are gonna [ __ ] they won't
even go into black know the black cannot
try and get the left you know of course
they are a [ __ ] I'm pretty sure Asian
American is the fastest-growing
ethnicity in America we look up fastest
crisis growing ethnicity in America okay
pretty thing not a bad thing yeah so so
that that's that's really and you don't
hear the left talking about that they've
talked themselves into a [ __ ] circle
here it's a real issue it's like if you
don't get serious about immigration
illegal in the great Americans their
bill that's wrestling Wow
major racial ethnic group in the United
States which would probably when you say
Asian forty eight countries in Asia as
we know but you know I think they're
talking about Koreans and Vietnamese and
love Chinese Chinese yeah yeah well yeah
they're showing what the the United
States can look like in a hundred years
and it's heavy heavy agent well no what
the United States look like in seven
years if you all be around I will not be
around if you're black you're you could
you could make the argument this is from
this is from black people who are
talking about this in these debates if
you're black
the biggest threat you face may very
well not be racism it may very well be
open borders and illegal immigration
because the Latin vote is going to
completely render your vote with theater
for everybody though right well not as
much whites cuz whites still are a
majority the majority black you if you
if you don't have control the borders in
the Latin vote it's gonna sway things
yeah that's gonna be a problem
this is no disrespect to Latin people or
anything else you guys know I love I
love that whole culture but I'm saying
it's an interesting irony that the
left-wing which is so against Trump's
immigration policy is going to have to
make it about faith if you don't
well you know you you everybody is
talking about black lives matter you
know my favorite thing is watching these
all these white corporations that are
run by white people with not one black
person on their board and they post they
post on social media I'm sure that
single mother that single black mother
in the hood is really breathing a sigh
Lee but you have that you are saying
you're not racist oh thanks I hope this
all happened Nike how out of well Nike
and Adidas that's a different animal
yeah
they employ a lot of I mean not really
not not in the upper echelon Nike death
yet Jordan oh yeah Jordan but that's the
biggest brand that's true but if you
little eye if you look at most of the
people that work don't look corporate
but yeah corporate yeah that's all what
I'm not saying that's I'm not saying
they're racist for that I'm saying
that's how things panned out and stuff
but it's just there's a lot of fun I'll
because it's Juneteenth
yeah with Juneteenth how about Trump is
so out of touch with what's going on
he's gonna throw his rally in Texas
today no Ike on Juneteenth you think
yeah why not yeah he is so toned uh-huh
but how does the team around him not be
like a they do there isn't I don't know
if they do like before the gun that I
can't you know because he just didn't
make up Juneteenth June 19th rally on
his own like there's a whole there's a
whole working [ __ ] machine there how
did nobody go up no you had on the 20th
did it's it's so is that such bad taste
it's not unifying at all this guy is
about his own reelection I've always
said it Donald Trump are there are the
good things about the guy and what he's
done for the economy 100% but this
[ __ ] guy he's about Trump yes Dylan
he's does he's about Trump pissed on
first he's about Trump's reelection
first
that's why photo opportunities are more
important than substance it's just true
he's he's about publicity his celebrity
yeah that's what it is I'm sorry but you
can say what you want but that's what's
going on here that just is and so when
you say never heard of it until it up
till the controversy of Ronnie's rally
Oh said he made it famous he just
yes so out of tune with what's going on
especially how do you not know American
history being the president of the
United States well he doesn't read it's
crazier well but but we know this and
we've always known this
Trump has good instincts when it comes
to the economy but you have to give him
credit or if some credit at least not
all the credit for the lowest
unemployment rate among African
Americans among Latinos among people of
color in the history or in past 50 years
you got to give him credit for that
before this Khurana [ __ ] with that but
neither sides good then look at Biden
hear him talk about the yeah you know
did Jim T June Juneteenth and you know
black black Wall Street was shut down
like he just he's what if you guys
killer Mike is my favorite American
killer Mike he's my favorite Americans
music now all I do is you know now I do
is watch him speak brilliant this
[ __ ] is he knows that all the
scholars many of whom I've read thank
you but but all the scholars on the left
and the right this mother and he's read
them all and he is so they're they
they're ti and Kansas Owens and they're
all fighting about its Trump good Trump
sucks he's bad got the left wing you got
right wing you got pro Trump supporters
he got pro burning supporting on and
kill Mike goes he just literally says
the n-word 15 times and goes you guys
are all talking about who has the best
master and it was like everybody went oh
yeah everybody was all black and thing
and he's like he goes you you got a
until you have your own thing that is
not a conversation that you got to get
out of that this dude thinks outside the
box in a way like some people are so
[ __ ] smart you're like guy really
he's so smart so articulate and his
thought this [ __ ] through deeply it's
brilliant it's very exciting and with
run the jewels you know he does it with
a white guy oh no what is run the jewels
is hip-hop man oh do oh I gotta say I'll
be listening to him I'd vote for that
dude yeah I that dude is just practical
pro legalization of marijuana why
because most of the young black kids in
[ __ ] in jail in his neighborhood or
elsewhere get a marijuana rap sheet and
then they it stops them from getting
[ __ ] jobs the dude has an
understanding of the local politics like
nobody's business came in hot today
the black labs that I did but it's
appropriate it's Juna it's june team for
sure first duty so who's actually that's
it that's his guy run the jewels Wow and
they were supposed to a concert with
Rage Against the Machine into this
covert hit you could have saw Rage
Against the Machine and run the covetous
spiked we're gonna be in San Antonio but
what's going on are we are we getting
some relief from covert or is the
numbers is it because there's more
testing who you talk to
right depends who you talk are people in
our people in that hospitals nope but
the testings going up and the as clay
Travis says the fair poen is real out
there because now it's like oh testings
going up be the second wave and then
foul she goes there's gonna be no NFL I
went when do we stop listen if out gee
where you know he's an expert he did
some good stuff on HIV so but when do we
realize he didn't eyes he didn't do such
good stuff well I'm just saying you can
reference that if you're a fan of him
but all I'm saying is when do we realize
it he doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about well when do we know that
he doesn't know that like even Trump
came I guess he doesn't know anything
like Danis dead enough Falchi is a very
cautious man he's a doctor his job in a
way is to be cautious his job in a way
is to think worst-case scenario that's
his job but you have to be careful with
a doctor if I went to a [ __ ] brain
surgeon and said I'm boxing and sparring
even lightly what would he say do you
think do you think he'd tell me to do it
or not he wouldn't look at the good
things I get out of it he'd only look at
the bad things and that's how we are as
human here's the problem everyone picks
sides so now it's Trump versus Falchi
it's Trump first Corona instead of
Justice Coronas disease and looking at
the facts
now it's if you're anti Corona I mean
you don't think speaking deals is your
pro Trump yeah and if you're if you want
to wear masters stuff then you're you
know you're on this the problem is both
sides go I'm looking at the science you
and I are going we're looking at the
data side it's like nobody can even
watch a science I don't get it well look
you like like Clay Travis said if you're
34 and honor you are have a better
chance of being killed by lightning than
Quran twice I mean come on come on at
least let the young out at least yet let
lately
give it up to them please let them with
now it's law you wear a mask in the
California now cover your mouth and
stand far away from people I have a
problem with that government overreach I
know I don't know what we're gonna do
Ben mm-hmm it is what it is it's a it's
a weird 2020 is you know Corona
but I always I'm an optimist and I think
you'll get through it
what I'll see you to do are you wearing
your off-white what are all these
sneakers doing it this killer you just
now know I've noticed I did I did a
complex show called full-size run it's
all sneakerheads and we talk about
sneakers so they wanted me to I want to
shoot in here not my house so I brought
in all my favorite sneakers so is so
hard to choose so just like they're all
Nike by the way which I really really
mess with Nike yeah like he's done a
very good job collabing with artists
yeah is that what these are uh yeah
every single one of those now collapse
those now are these awful just sick so
you do you describe them as sick or dope
dope dope so dope is the word you use
yes please tell me what's dope about the
purple ones they're just the purple join
ones yeah just a different color with
tie-dye laces I would say on that table
is about close to 10 grand 10 grand
probably close in shoes yep close even
if I pulled out a pistol and just proven
into a [ __ ] box and ran out so we got
there's two of those in the world
they're two of these in the world PJ
Tucker and me what what and you had to
have them because you want fur well my
boy shoe surgeon made them they're
custom made shoe surgeon now you've worn
them exactly zero times twice what I
like about you is you do wear expensive
[ __ ] you'll wear them yeah these some
people put it on Oh Spence if she's a
cow beat up these up does your most
expensive yeah those are the off-white
yeah what are they what they cost you I
don't know
bring rapture no no like two grand day
two grand
I got a matte price oh you got a right
amount just go up in value where they
called the off-white oh those are very
cools yeah these are super old-school
are they do you were in Seoul stuff here
I have to plantar fasciitis because I
wear so many shoes you have to wear
insoles oh yeah well your your big kid
those are used for a hundred twelve
hundred Jesus Christ let's sell these
[ __ ] shoes dude
this is amazing see if you go to so the
lowest the low she can get them is 1300
but if you go on do those sizes chin
couldn't go up for our left scroll down
to sizes and then scroll down 13 so 1300
if you wear uh 11 a half their 2,700 oh
my shoes because so many people want yep
9 half 2 grand
what what about 10 and 1/2 that's me 13
what oh [ __ ] I want to be cool and I
don't know I'm wearing my bare ass
throughout state you rogue in sneakers
they're just older dude they're under we
don't know if you guys have a show where
shoes don't matter have a mom one person
that cares less about clothing than me
is Joe Rogan he'll use ones like
functionally he's never cared about yeah
she's never cared yeah we're kung-fu
jeans yeah that some company got him I
couldn't I
they could cover me I cable pay 10 grand
to wear these jeans and that happening
never know now you you are you pay
attention to style it's it makes you
feel better
I've never seen you not take your
threads into consideration even when I
go to the gym I dress for comfort so
Kashmir we missed yesterday at did at
the the gym how was it great yeah I was
there opening back up fully the other
thing today's the first day good for
them
I know good for Jack's good fun for us
good for them yeah no more gym time on
our own mm-hmm no more it's called
tempest gym by the way Jeff does campus
gym oh great
Jeff has been the quarantine MVP yeah my
son flood was allowed to go in that gym
and just go buck wild and he would run
until he was he ran up he ran so much
SAT through up he threw up all over his
shirt and his Papa take my shirt off it
threw up Mike from what cuz I spend
pretty than hard he is like candy before
us I took the shirt off so he's running
little muscles are out he's best friends
with Jeff Foley's it's funny yes
yes that's right I know he loves her so
much yeah it's so funny to watch you you
call him Papa yeah so great papa
but he looks like you when you were a
little kid Oh like it to a tee
to a tee like in every aspect bah bah
he's gonna be a monster he's gonna March
to the Boston nuts hoot using me almost
seven months now it's just like dude
yeah
I'm just kiddin yes so came out so big
yeah he was great this like if like
we're on the road last week I came home
they put my arms like well he's grown
two feet he's shut I'm like what are we
gonna do a little partner he's a baby
was headed 99 percentile head which is
never good no means give me a big he's
so big his hands and feet I'm like a
losing me offensive tackle
yeah I have Tony Boselli as a kid that's
right yes Orlando pace as Orlando pace
as the baby just boss baby Orlando pace
the guy with the crazy neck bring up
Orlando pace he played Ohio State he's
probably the best alignment of all time
god it's really college football this is
my son at seven months old this guy and
he looks like him that the same face yep
yes look at him wait a minute
look at his let's boss traps and how
wide his faces and his hands and all the
pancakes I wonder what is it what did he
weigh I wonder what he cut he's one of
the best of all time bait one of the
best ever do it play for the rarest son
who is that Hall of Famer I mean all
other players at the school they're your
that's what I mean my son looks
identical to that pancake dude he look
at hid the way he's built he's just like
traps and a face that goes on forever
from east to west I told my girl Michael
what point do we put this kill on a diet
like to eat do we start limiting carbs
she said she just wants to eat just let
him become a huge he's 324 pounds six
seven he's six seven six foot seven well
in some ways he might be the strongest
man in the world and might be the most
athletic I mean at that size stupid
footwork just a straight monster with
speed oh yeah one of the best ever do it
dude I mean he I think he's on all
century team he's
criminal house date and and and his job
was to be a wall and now that you
through when he's a left tackle so
that's where that's besides the
quarterback then boys make money because
they got protect the cash cow right so
you can't get through him mm-hmm
now what is the for the layman like
myself what is what is it what is the
technique in blocking I feel like you
just have to go like this and keep
people away but that's a stupid SF the
ball you get the best footwork thing
maybe you never seen them where they
they take their that that that this this
thought like this going back there's a
because they got the the monsters of all
the NFL the d-ends and the outside
linebackers rushing so like Von Miller
and these freaks you know D and the bomb
knowledge a [ __ ] freak so they what
makes Von Miller special and you know
like these other monsters coming off the
edge those heads Russia's are paid to
make all the money it's all about speed
so we're Lana pace his first step and
think about he's six seven to his
wingspan is insane
so his first step you gotta get around
wall you guys get around it but you know
I don't think people realize if you
don't follow about how big some of those
guys are it's the craziest [ __ ] you've
ever seen the first time I saw like I
saw five football players together in an
audition room they all played for the
Jets and they were doing something and I
was with Jimmy Burke and I I you know me
I'm obsessed with power and size and I'm
gay so huge and I couldn't stop looking
at them there was a jet his name was
Eric Dorsey maybe I don't know yeah a
hand or see maybe I've never seen it
before New York giant no no he was a
this guy african-american man who was oh
oh there's some 70s it may as well been
yeah that was him
dude when you see him in person and you
see how big and strong he is it's weird
and he played a long time yeah this was
new 90s yeah I'd never seen anything
like it though I I kept saying to Jimmy
I go look at him I'd never seen anything
like it
he was so big and strong and so I got
never see any have you ever seen footage
of like jr. sale when he played
basketball in high school no or or like
Mercedes Lewis when he played basketball
hi
or Julius Peppers you're like oh they're
just good at football they're getting
everything good jr. sale was the most
dominant player in California basketball
what is ridiculous Oh see there you go
like you see I didn't eat some a kid
that's him yeah he's better at
basketball he was football they say that
was him in high school because he looks
40 so he's also the Samoan of the
Samoans and he also had a mullet so
that's cool Wow how tall was do you play
ball six four six five six three I think
and it was the was it was that good at
basketball sir amazing at basketball
ridiculous at basketball but then you
look at Julius Peppers you ever seen him
for North Carolina is the people you
know people refer to like Jevon Kearse
is the freak you ever seen his fingers
son his palm yes it's five longer mentor
on cursor I spent some time with all the
freaking hands like that in my life but
now Julius Peppers the ultimate freak oh
you want play basketball Papa get a shot
off on him at North Carolina play for a
North Carolina best one football I mean
that's so stupid
dude it's and then went and played pro
football still playing he might still be
on team but he's no no call it quits
that's for 17 years one of the best 17
here when the best ever do it
17 years tall yeah just the treasure so
straight savage I would personally love
to look that way I would personally be a
pinky I personally maybe say right you
can live to 70 or 90 and I might go give
me a second I got to think about if I
want 20 years just so I could just look
like that I'd rather look like that and
just just own the world
yeah or just or be waiting boy you know
that good I don't know that must've been
so much fun how much fun is that did it
become a job after a while I mean yeah
that's a good question well there you go
that's what's that guy right there with
it yeah now again if you think you're an
athlete or you think you're Moscow oh no
I got what I was looking at this guy on
Instagram he's a starting pitcher I
think for the Yankees or Oakland A's
you're gonna love it's gonna hurt my
feelings
hold on you know OSP for the UFC great
body huge ass right think of him but six
seven and bigger
and he's a starting pitcher those 103
miles an hour you want to hit that 103
miles now let me find out mm-hmm yeah
pictures got a big buck I just thought
in bigger well no that's not I can just
have focus awaiting other vision they
all have butts
these players need their butts hey can
we cut for a second yeah Jenna those
total human optimization packets I'm
looking at right now they are you got
day support and night support that's
what on it's got total human
optimization day and night support
that's a lot of people don't realize you
might need nutrients wet for recovery if
you train hard at night a lot of people
forget that if you want to focus their
flagship of course is what alpha brain
something Joe Rogan takes every time he
does a podcast something you say yeah
every time you do a podcast and then so
I think I doubt for brain instant alpha
brain tablets you know I've never really
taken out the brain but since a lot of
the smart people I know take it I think
I'm gonna start maybe I should rip some
that freakin krill oil on your eyelids
let me tell you let me do a testimony on
gut health total gut health I ate bad
sushi when I tell you I was nauseous for
one month every day it would hit me I'd
be nauseous I'll tell your fart fart and
then you got on the the gut health you
don't fart as much yeah well but this is
a different one where I was always
[ __ ] nauseous and I took three days
of total gut health and it went away so
they will restore your gut health
because they've done a lot of science on
this oh they are the cutting-edge
science on the gut detail and I'm
telling you guys for if your coffee
heads like me coffee for your head
okay yeah coffee it's black rifle collab
with on it to make the most intense dark
roast coffee you've ever had they got
protein they got fitness gear apparel
nutrition supplements safe temperature
on 10% on everything go to on it Cobb
slash fighter
10% off you're welcome mmm-hmm he's a
he's a all right he's a large fella how
they calling the Cuban missle now now
remember Pitt moon nolan ryan good
pictures we're rolling right
look like Clint Eastwood yeah now try
hitting off the Cuban missile look on
the far right the vco el Romero look
like a high schooler I think he throws
like a hundred for something crazy
Oh you--oh else on his page yeah he's
pitch for the Yankees okay yeah well
he's enormous
now he's six I don't know six eight or
some [ __ ] like there's all the six Keats
imagine trying to hit that ball I mean
for me if I can see if I can see the
does six four games like the 212 that
this looks huge though he's so big yeah
I think he's bigger than 212 his arms
our legs so I think he's he's more than
that
hey you always find out you're like how
much - forty I can guarantee he's bigger
than 212 well they got on the left has
Malik legs yeah little juice you're that
where is that the guy on the right is
the guy on the right needs to get a bike
and join the big boy bike club that's a
big guy but for a pitcher dude I'm
pretty sure he feels like hundred four
you got to start swinging the minute it
leaves his hand Brennan that's what I've
always said sort of my life what that's
the best pitch ever recorded oh my god
is there a video of that that's [ __ ]
nuts buddy hit it well he did in Arizona
we were gonna stand in front of that the
guy who pitches 100 I wasn't gonna do
that remember I don't want to do that
I'm afraid of it
me too I'm afraid of all things baseball
okay let's just him warming up here it
goes 99
I get paid reverse who's fun done this a
thousand times it doesn't seem various
yeah Oh hundred miles an hour this I
miss baseball Shah did still get his
batter before getting his bat around on
that 104 is there Annette there yeah oh
I look crazy
105 that looks these guys are not afraid
of the fall he was trying to do is get
that hundred 500 get a home off of him
okay well that oh no you know what 105
looks the same as 90 to me yeah it does
that's a hundred four dude he's throwing
as we call it in the in the big leaf
gasps gasps Dylan gasps and he's got a
tail piece on him well it looks like
your speed doesn't it sure that a little
bit like OSB yep 105 105 broke the
battery don't remember Randy Johnson
yeah I want to get that bird yup yup 611
leave it no he's your crazy think he's
212 yeah you're crazy if you think it's
212 you're crazy
he's built like an ostrich he's got the
biggest butt I've ever seen
so you have an ostrich in your shorts
sir that ostrich Blaine baseball yeah
you have it you have a muscular ostrich
now is he playing baseball these booty
pitches for the pay look at that look at
the power of this team in the world
yeah oh here we go Jesus rice oh let me
see if I can do this [ __ ] no I don't
think we did I can barely get my battery
over six now laughs all off of this no
you're not getting your bat around in
time how's that guys not how hard is the
scare the catcher's he's not wearing any
he's playing a pro too though Howard
amassing these are professional I can't
just be your boy catch a home right now
what's going on with his class does he
have three cups on Casey misses Jesus
Christ strike I don't see it right and
and Kevin told me that when his guy
pitches 100% he'll never hit me no their
controls insane you kidding me
their control is insane but it's
possible they can hit
that's what I always say maybe but they
can still hit you like in the [ __ ]
thigh scary not cool though yes yeah
maybe it's six how do you were six four
boys making money though mmm-hmm pretty
cool huh
hopefully baseball comes back I think
it's maybe better just they do a sixty
game season right it's what baseball
needs because they usually play 182
games so no one's watching all those
games you 60 games it's kind of like
turns the NFL because then every game is
important every guy's trying the pitcher
is gonna get rest they're gonna be able
to pitch you're gonna get key players
playing longer it's got no caps not in
that smallest caps in that picture the
pretty small and and well I have to
believe that that picture wasn't
doctored to make his cab small though
let's in there cuz the white stripes on
the other side
I think his calves are mi I don't here's
pitch 106 now and you see a lot of guys
who are super fast and super athletic we
don't have calves oh yeah here's Malik
keV he's got Miley calves and he's
tatted to the gills he looks like the
game he looks cool and that outfit that
shirt is just oh no no where I come from
I'd say - no no yeah you know who can
only wear those shirts the Cuban Missile
and campaign that's other than that
don't wear this cam wear those told not
to he's canceled he's roughly my age
he's back he's hunting and I tell not to
yeah let me see yeah maybe I was
Instagram
yeah isn't done in a while maybe stop
maybe listen to us there it is yeah
that's what he rocks it's that's kind of
okay that's still hmm it's not so no no
for me but it's not but the audience can
do whatever the hell you want the cue
missiles wearing a different shirt go
back to the cocoon is those agencies
nipples cuz that's a black I cut
something and if I guys if I see your
tits yeah you're you're cutting you're
not why we're a shirt
don't show me nipples I think the rule
is can't see your nips no nips yeah
that's an issue what else your chin
would you encourage chairman all right
don't yell it one sec yeah just take
over Jim okay do you have her event so
you need her to do it I didn't look at
him but I'll try any one sec all right
check this out let's see this together
oh my god they weren't tight too calm
with the beer that closed them did they
see there's a black bear that's the good
news
that's a black bear just slow the beers
like that's pretty calm personally it's
why I hike with a gun yeah that's scary
it's [ __ ] very scary people are and they
said rather to come you should always
stay calm you don't wanna scream you
want to just get up the way you don't
the bear was not afraid no the girls
pretty gangster though yet they most
people were panicked I would have walked
real slow and as soon as he can't see I
would have [ __ ] ran for the help
just slow so well you don't the thing is
they start filming a while ago so do
they see it come let go let's film this
yeah baby
which is nuts go ahead Jim all right
officer Karen I'm reaching meme status I
think that shit's funny that's what she
said Georgia surf W went viral this week
after posting a video in which she's she
broke down in tears and begged the Pope
to give law enforcement a break I don't
know how much more I can take
I didn't see this I know it's going all
over do we have the video for a crime I
I have to say cuz I had said something I
took some heat for the last podcast
where I was like I actually looked at
that taser thing with Rashard Brooks yes
and and Djokovic's was like if you don't
train for this you panic and you shoot
iiiii he did turn and discharged the
Taser but I do feel like there was I
feel likely to shoot I wasn't bright I
mean I'm sick I wish you could have
chased him because I didn't need to
shoot because 41 minutes he was jovial
and listening to
and then then he started resisting
arrest and then I've never been in that
situation you need us but I understand
how people are like dude you know I
understand how how again I don't this
that should happen so fast he turns
everything you like whatever but I easy
is there any hey if you're a cop let me
ask you this maybe somebody can hit me
up on this mm is there a world where you
can shoot somebody in the knees you have
to film in the gas you know I mean I
don't think I don't think they they
panic under that but there's got to be a
reason why social so when when
somebody's running away from you and
he's not gonna damn you it's not gonna
kill anybody hard to shoot the news yeah
yeah but if somebody's running away from
you and he's not he doesn't have a gun
or or whatever to shoot him in the back
his good baby see this video unless
you're going to kill somebody else right
here like you shouldn't be able to do
this is the care lady looks like well I
decided to come to the McDonald's at
loves on the Ford Avenue exit and I
waited in line to get my food I had
already done my mobile order so that you
know people don't pay for my stuff
because I just always like to pay for it
myself
but I'm on my way home from work when I
pull up to the window they hand me my
receipt so I go to the second window to
get my food and I'm waiting and I'm
waiting and I'm waiting and so the girl
comes to the window and asks me what my
order was I repeat my order and my
coffee order and they asked me to pull
it because my foods not ready it's an
English muffin meal with a hash brown
coffee and I mean I hadn't eaten since
probably about I mean I've been up for
very long time but I haven't eaten in a
while so it's kind of ugly and I'm still
waiting and I'm still waiting and they
asked me to pull up so I pull it forward
in
a girl comes out with my coffee and just
the coffee and she hands it to me and my
window down and that's all she hands me
as a coffee so I told her I said don't
bother with the food because right now
I'm too nervous to take it it doesn't
matter how many hours I've been up it
doesn't matter what I've done for anyone
right now I'm too nervous to take a meal
from McDonald's because I can't see it
being made I don't know what's going on
with people nowadays but please just
give us a break please just give us a
break I don't know how much more I can
take
service for 15 years and I've never ever
had such anxiety about waiting for
McDonald's drive-through food so just
have a heart and if you see an officer
just doesn't because I don't care thank
you enough anymore
there you go oh I want it just like
McMuffin it's just uh it's it's it's a
world we are very [ __ ] polarized and
and you know it's it's we have to do
something about it it's it's just like
casting everybody every cop is a bad guy
or whatever it's just not good for
anybody yeah so Sox icon award six
billion to build the city in Senegal
right so what's sick look Akana has been
award a six billion dollar contract to
build a city in Senegal he was working
with Senegal government to build a
tourist City that used cryptocurrency
based economy who is a kcon he's singer
singer I'm locked up it won't let me and
he's he's Senegalese her yes and he's
been given six billion dollars to God
Akon lighting African till I'm 14 which
provides electricity in 15 countries of
Africa and charity for underprivileged
children Akon city will run on 100 cent
renewable energy did expect to be fully
completed by 2030 Wow take some time to
build
my friend who shot frank grillo shot in
senegal said it was one of the greatest
place we've ever been is it nice he said
he loved it the people more than
anything is he give me called a concert
about something else
hey constantly something else I'd like
to go there that looks beautiful though
how do you get to sit again it's in the
west coast of Africa so beautiful people
who fly in direct mostly Sufi Muslim
which there's tend to be mystic very
tolerant people some of the tallest
multi most athletic and beautiful people
in the world
that's ones you the guys you showed us
that are just built yeah yeah but the
women and the men they're all yeah
everyone usually they're just tall and
they just look like [ __ ] avatars it's
gorgeous
yeah Frank Frank was like oh I'm really
short what are you thinkin so your
Bronco is coming out is it beginneth
this year or an extra supposed to come
out in October October early release um
so this hit made the headlines Nicole
Brown Simpson said that the Ford Bronco
I guess the original release date was
July 9th which also happens to be a J
Simpsons birthday and they thought it
was a joke
I think it's a coincidence Julie I think
it is okay
anyhow okay so they did change it after
yeah obviously they found out that his
type great-looking Tron I want it
post one July 13th in 2021 porn is are
they saying this year because I'm told I
can't get October that's a long time I
feel like it's you can get the 2021
Bronco but you'll get it this year some
for some reason that's usually how they
do it yeah but this is st. comes out
July 13th that's not a week
Brock his official debut date post
playing yet again July night the bronc
will now greet the world Monday June
13th almost sir well it's already here
man sis seven yet this Bronco runs wild
seven nine yeah so what why why are they
tell me October they're like oh you're
on some list you get in October if I
ain't got the dealer and buy one and J
they make a misprint here they met July
13th right yeah am i tripping yeah okay
that's a misprint yeah July 13th saw one
more mom keeps growing down mm-hmm the
two versions of 2021 for
debut on July 13th yeah so this year all
right well maybe I'll have to wait
October t Doherty says he's gonna become
he wants to become an officer either
Sheriff or an actual patrolman I don't
think he just jumped to sheriff this is
what he says you know I'm saying I plan
on it just spend on what rank and I want
to do do I want to be a sheriff or do I
want to be a police officer
I've been made my decision yet I'll be
fighting one more time here I want to
hang him up but I want to do something
else that will not just keep the
excitement going but just do what's
right for the country do what's right
for the city of a good cop you'd be
great but she hides in Beach yeah that's
weird is it common hunting yeah I'm
probably busy busy but also you can't
just be sure yeah even if you're
celebrities and I like you're a captain
yeah you're not gonna want to resist
arrest with Tito Nang he's been in
high-pressure situation so I'm sure he's
a great cop that's true he's a nice guy
he's a good guy yes yes fans of Tito
take a look at this this is kind of good
news so Wow a federal judge is okay
housing for 7,000 homeless people but
then they all if they also like her at a
certain age and they're more susceptible
to the corner of ours so they're gonna
move them out a problem with this is
that a lot of times it's not a homeless
issue it's mental health drug and
addiction and mental illness issue so
it's nice to get them in there but until
you have legislation that allows as
tricky it's very tricky but if you if
you until you allow police officers and
people who educated task forces let's
put it this way who can corral these
people and put them in facilities and
treatment centers even sometimes against
their will because they're schizophrenic
or they're walking around with you know
the dirt all over their body and feces
those people should you should be
allowed to in under strict guidelines
protect them from themselves and put
them in treatment centers and until we
do that this is all [ __ ] lip service
yes till you realize that the homeless
crisis is there another [ __ ] issue
with them I have with the left it's like
it's not a home and I'm being a little
unfair because I'm sure they understand
it but it's not a home
not a housing issue this is a mental
health and [ __ ] drug issue come on
man
come on come on but these guys live in
LA I see it every day so yeah maybe we
just also say these guys are everywhere
so they're gonna take him off of these
streets which is good a good thing yeah
what can a alright Jamie Foxx is gonna
play Mike Tyson in a biopic oh and then
this is yeah pic he'd be great and then
this is some picture she showed but it's
confusing because it seems like he
actually got to this size but then when
they talk it sounds like it's movie
magic so I'll play for you picture
he's a muscular guy I've no doubt Wow so
now it looks like young Mike right there
young Mike and here's the other one
so once that happens it'll be magic
because I saw your arms of the day and
I'm just saying they weren't so so they
want that huh what did I say the other
day you weren't ripped like that some
movie magic is real so once that happens
way to go dude what's that and that was
a that was a picture like this a you
know like a couple of months ago
what's that happens then we'll start to
add on who he is and what he is just the
way he orders us through what he cares
about and I think that's what will make
the movie go he's so smart so so
talented and by the way he'll get he's
thick Jamie's thick he's in video four
he's never seen me in any given Sunday
yes he's naturally bring on that when
he's Willie Beamen really benign you get
him on a little a little juice and you
get him lifting I guarantee he's gonna
look a lot like Tyson yeah thanks and
you know that's cool man yeah all right
so the bold and the beautiful the soap
opera they're coming back to film right
yes
oh I'm so glad you covered this is yes
they're gonna be using blog dolls for
the sex scenes now okay oh oh oh what
the [ __ ]
who is that guy that might be my buddy
Texas battle it's a young dude
good-looking people uh-huh that's
interesting
all right let's go move over to this
I just saw this and you know how like
barceló coast so this chick is very
interesting and what is she what is she
for Barcia Jesus just a smoke show of
the day kind of thing but she was like a
tiny girl with just gigantic boobs
Jesus hi good for you Jen name is Hannah
C Palmer it's nice to be nice yep
correct Wow yeah this bar stool still do
some graduate shops I haven't seen it
recently a little less how was it yeah
yeah there that's definitely one of them
all right let's see it's time yet again
take a break from real life and say hi
to Hannah Palmer you know what all right
I might have been well hello is that it
that's pretty much it
wait wait I'll just show you one more
this is just like I'm going to paint a
picnic bench with my kids Mike Perry so
he's supposed to have a fight it was
like what happened do we know what
happened to him they say no but I'm
wondering if this is just like a makeup
thing uh no that would be real yeah or
something you would imagine he got into
some sort of fight was on but I don't
know after what happened he looks like
he just slaughtered like 50 people with
his bare hands
you looking like a bag chin many years
like are you gonna give yo you imagine
that's a laptop bag oh yeah yeah I have
to take care of laptops yeah wonder what
that what Perry was doing there I don't
know but he looks pretty damaged I mean
is that enough to stop a fight for the
Commission that head cuts a little
trouble knuckles no but the head the
head gets trouble so she would the
placement yeah we'll see it's a tough
fight make you go fun fight I might get
a nice bag travel back I said I told you
guys i sat next to Donna McDonald in
McNab on the plane that was a lie he sat
behind him he's a thicky he is as
muscular and big and strong he it's like
that well sir do you do you play middle
linebacker and you lift all the weights
well but he had a Gucci backpack that
was very tasteful might think it was
good you and I got for you I kind of
coveted it I went for who wouldn't mind
having that
wouldn't be for you daddy no no very
nice man very thick as thick as great
great football player rather strong man
looking very strong huge arms doesn't
look like a quarterback no very very
good player though yeah and not as tall
as I thought good way to 6 feet maybe
yeah I don't think more than 6 feet
there you go which one did he have that
you like Bob I like these
yeah the other one it was a knapsack so
it was you know you want a satchel daddy
no no I'm not gonna get one it's not for
me that one down there which one it was
like the bag yeah not for you dude not
for me
I'll change that's it come see us in
early Sariah to have energy today mad
yet energy come see us in San Antonio
that's right 25 26 27 X Thursday Friday
Saturday Club yes lol hey buddy I can't
wait my Salt Lake City shows are sold
out we add it we're gonna add a Thursday
so don't don't worry Salt Lake City the
16th of July we ran the show to that
Thursday rest of my sold out.we I told
you guys you change the date for spoken
it's supposed to be next weekend but we
changed it to July 30th August 1st so
I'm in Spokane Irvine we'll be in August
yeah in our end of August which I'll
release tickets for that Tampa and
Austin and Nashville on sale right now
t5k calm for everything related to Brian
and myself fake boy calm for all the
merch all right
be nice each other in love you guys
we're out